aquí tenemos cuatro cuadriláteros lo que
quiero que pensemos en este vídeo es
cuáles de estos cuadriláteros tienen la
misma área que el cuadrilátero verde de
acá este que es un trapecio bueno aquí
te recomiendo que detengas el vídeo para
intentar este problema por tu cuenta
saleh voy a suponer que pasaste el vídeo
y que ya lo intentaste te voy a contar
cómo lo haría yo la forma en la que lo
haría es dividiendo este trapecio en
figuras más sencillas lo voy a hacer de
la siguiente forma voy a trazar una
línea que vaya de este punto a este
punto de acá le voy a hacer así
y voy a trazar otra que vaya de este
punto a este punto de acá le voy a hacer
así y con esto nos damos cuenta que en
realidad este trapecio está formado por
tres figuras más simples un rectángulo
que tiene tres de alto y uno dos tres
cuatro cinco de ancho y dos triángulos
estos dos pequeños triángulos que de
hecho son idénticos y no sólo eso si los
juntamos forman un rectángulo déjame
hacer esto para que veas aquí a qué me
refiero este triángulo lo voy a pasar
aquí abajo lo voy a poner por aquí ya es
un poquito más arriba por ahí sale y por
ahí este triángulo lo estoy pasando para
acá déjame pintarlo en color verde de
este mismo color verde algo así algo de
este estilo vale a lo mejor puede que se
te complique un poco visualizarlo pero
entonces puedes pensarlo así este
triángulo puedes voltearlo golpearlo
hacia allá déjame lo dibujo para que
veas cómo queda queda volteado quedaría
algo de este estilo
algo más o menos así a lo mejor no me
queda muy derechito pero espero que se
vea la idea entonces éste lo volteamos
se convierte en este de acá luego
podemos girar lo girarlo para que quede
como algo de este estilo y simplemente
lo trasladamos para acá sale entonces
que estamos logrando con esto estamos
logrando ver que estos dos triángulos en
realidad se juntan para hacer un
rectángulo que mide cinco de largo y uno
de alto vale bueno pero está padrísimo
porque eso nos dice que el área el área
del trapecio en realidad es la misma que
el área de un rectángulo que tiene cinco
de ancho y cuatro de alto le voy a poner
aquí cuatro y de este lado cinco
entonces con esto podemos determinar el
área del trapecio simplemente hay que
ver cuál es el área del rectángulo y eso
sabemos hacerlo verdad podemos
simplemente contar los cuadrados déjame
hacer eso lo voy a poner en color
amarillo y voy a tomar el pincel para
que se vea 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 tiene
20 cuadrados de uno por uno de una
unidad cuadrada y por lo tanto su área
es 20 en realidad sabíamos hacer eso de
otra forma verdad una forma más sencilla
también podemos multiplicar los lados
que sería 5 x por 4 y eso también nos
daría 20 déjalo a punto ahí en medio en
este color que se ve a 20 entonces el
área de este trapecio es 20 vamos a ver
qué figuras tienen la misma área que el
trapecio déjame pasar a este rectángulo
de acá este rectángulo también lo
podemos dividir en dos figuras más
sencillas esta es un rectángulo verdad
este cuadrilátero me refiero este
cuadrilátero lo podemos dividir en un
rectángulo y en un triángulo en un
triángulo aquí abajo un triángulo
rectángulo pero no tenemos que tan sólo
este rectángulo tiene lados
y 4 de modo que su área es 20 el área de
aquí ya es 20 y esto de aquí es
adicional entonces este cuadrilátero
tiene más área que el trapecio de acá
pasemos al azul en el azul tenemos que
el ancho es 5 y el alto estrés de modo
que tiene área 5 por 3 o sea 15 el área
es menor que este de acá y finalmente
pasemos al rectángulo rojo el rectángulo
rojo se ve interesante
aquí tenemos lados de 5 y 4 de modo que
su área es 5 x 4 ósea 20 20 y 20 es la
misma área que este de acá entonces el
cuadrilátero rojo es el único que tiene
la misma área que nuestro trapecio verde